[Music]
eyes in the ring all right that's our
target shadows one and two push to your
luck points let's invite
this could be a draft
actual we're set
guppy get to work
i want full containment
cut right clear through
[Music]
[Music]
room clear coming up
[ __ ] door
we're moving to the main deck what's
your status boarding ship with shadow
three now roger
[Applause]
run down
we gotta roll
they're gonna launch that missile
it's first stage there's no time all
shadows all shadows missile is on the
helipad
two one we're moving to secure
coverage off
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
objective is neutralized
where are the controls
on that damn ship
actually we got a problem
on the ship you have your orders son
stop that launch
effective fire the lp will be hot to
that once we're on deck we push to the
bridge fast secure those controls stop
this vessel yep how do we board
take the ramp
all night
let's have ourselves a gunfight
missile controls are on the bridge
[Music]
perfect
between them
[Music]
oh
copy that
all right stand back this is shadow one
going explosive on bridge entry
three two one execute
[Music]
pre-order now and get early access to
the open beta